all right time to answer some questions
will green away three wants to know what
are the patriots speaking of brady going
to do at the quarterback position and
this came up yesterday with tom kern tom
kind of downplayed it
i think the pressure is on the patriots
to upgrade especially
with tom brady and the buccaneers due to
come to new england for a game this year
which undoubtedly will be in prime time
yeah and mike you see all the players
they have coming back this could be a
good football team if they can
settle the quarterback position if they
get jimmy garoppolo as you
speculated that would be great for them
i think they can win with jimmy
garoppolo i don't know if they can win a
super bowl with jimmy garoppolo
but i do think they can contend for the
division with the bills and get to the
playoffs and maybe have some plowed
success who knows with bill belichick
i know i wouldn't want to play bill
belichick in the playoffs that's for
sure
um yeah and uh look the the patriots are
not going to be out of the mix for very
long here they're going to find
somebody and i think there's a good
chance as we mentioned in the last
segment jimmy garoppolo could then back
end up back in new england all right
next question from i can ability in
light of how the jared goff and carson
wentz extensions have unraveled how
would you handle
baker mayfield this off season fifth
year option or full out extension
personally i'm a firm believer unless
you've got josh allen who i think
should be undoubtedly
locked into a long-term extension or
patrick mahomes who already is
i think with baker mayfield you wait i
think you definitely wait you know with
sam darnold he's got to prove it
and and you you're not interested at all
with mayfield yeah you're interested
but you're not ready to do it this year
shireen i i think the
the cleveland browns definitely should
wait a lot of money
into baker mayfield over the short term
and putting themselves potentially in a
position a year or two from now where
they regret it
yeah jared goff and carson wench should
have taught team
something mike you just don't do it
unless you're absolutely convinced
you look at what the bucks did with
jameis winston you look at what
um who else was it that tennessee did
with marcus mariota
and they let them play that out and
leave the bucks certainly
upgraded the titans think they upgraded
with ryan tannehill they at least got
the championship game last year with
tannehill they found him
for a cheap price from the dolphins so
it worked out for those teams it didn't
work out so well for the eagles it
didn't work out so well for the rams
i'm not convinced baker mayfield is the
franchise guy
you've got to let him play out another
year and see what he does before you
commit to him
yep and and uh the the ultimate warning
comes from those contracts done two
years ago
by the eagles and the rams for wentz and
goff respectively
jay luke wants to know will the
buccaneers be able to go
back to back has it happened since 2003
2004
used to happen more frequently the
salary cap era
i think is one of the big reasons why
it's ended the cowboys had
back to back in the early 90s right when
free agency and the salary cap were
starting to kick
in i think as more and more time goes by
what the patriots did
0304 is going to be more more impressive
because i think it's going to be hard to
do but frankly
if any team is built to do it it's the
tampa bay buccaneers barring injury
and injury is always the wild card in
this i i
look and it's it's easy to say because
we're still in the afterglow of what
happened on sunday but
i think they've got as good as chances
anyone has had in the past 20 years to
pull off the repeat shireen
and you know what helps him mike to me
it helps him being in the nfc you're
away from patrick mahomes you're away
from josh allen
you don't have to play those guys now i
know you got aaron rodgers i get that
and i get that you know the rams have
made some changes and you have russell
wilson but i still would rather
i think play those teams than have to go
through
patrick mahomes and josh allen i i just
think it's an easier route to get to the
super bowl and
you know the bucks have done it they
they've won one they're confident now i
mean they're talking like it today we'll
see what happens when when they come
back but
you know the chiefs figured out this
year remember after last year they
talked about
i know chris jones specifically said
we're going to get five rings six ring
seven rings whatever it went up to
however high it went
but it's hard to win one it's harder to
win
two and they learned that and i think
the bucks are going to learn that too
tom brady obviously already knows that
and one of the big factors is going to
be what these other teams in the nfc do
to get back to our earlier points
as it relates to going all in trying to
construct super teams with free agents
to help aaron rodgers to help russell
wilson
what will these teams below the
buccaneers do
to close the gap in the offseason that's
going to be a huge factor and whether or
not the bucks can get back
one more and i resisted this but we have
time to fill
matt kc9 i'm not familiar with that
twitter handle
asks how many times will you see saw on
you love kirk cousins and want him to
stay
versus you love kirk cousins not and
want him out that
goes back to something sims has accused
me of with kirk cousins you love him you
love him not look we had cousins on last
week
i think he's a great guy i think he's a
great quarterback the question is are
the
vikings good enough and is the vikings
attitude
we want to put together a championship
team or is it we're content
to just be good enough and frankly i
don't think they can move on from
cousins because
what's their alternative and mike zimmer
needs to have a decent year or he's
going to be fired
i think they're going to keep cousins
and they're going to try to be just good
enough
and just good enough means maybe get to
the division around maybe get lucky in
the divisional round and get to the
conference championship but i just don't
see the vikings
as putting together the kind of team in
one off season that can seriously
contend but i also see them
keeping kirk cousins because if they go
with anyone else
yeah and that's the thing mike zimmer is
going into this season under intense
pressure he's on the hottest of hot
seats when you start looking at
the bets of the first coach to go he's
at the top of that list mike and i just
think he has a lot of pressure to at
least
get to the playoffs and possibly win a
wild card game to keep his job and it's
going to be hard to do
even if he has kirk cousins but it's
going to be a little bit easier to do if
he has kirk cousins on his side but
this team just looks like it's headed
maybe to a rebuild after this season
with a new coach and a new quarterback
if they can't get it done
and look i said a year ago when cousins
was entering a contract year
zimmer was entering a contract year
dalvin cook in a contract year rick
spielman in a contract year my advice to
the wolfs was
publicly not privately but publicly i
said
don't sign any of them make them earn it
and if they do
good problem to have if they don't it's
easier
to move away and start over again that's
the problem they were inclined to
rebuild this year wasn't going to happen
next year it's going to be easier but
here's the other problem if kirk cousins
is on the team as of march 19
his 35 million dollar salary for 2022
becomes fully guaranteed and he told
us last week he's not interested in
extension he's got the vikings
the same spot even better than what he
had washington in a couple of years ago
he's got two more years he's going to
make 56 million and then a damn thing
the vikings can do to keep him off the
open market after 2022. so they're in a
tough spot and
i still don't rule out the possibility
of a trade the problem is
who is the replacement they love teddy
bridgewater
in minnesota but they may not love him
as much as they thought
once they see him play in comparison to
kirk cousins
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports